he had gotten around some you know
unsavory characters he was an unsavory
character himself and he just wasn't
meant to be a father
my mom was super young and uh
he was gone and that was it and what
that did for me
now that i can look back on it while it
was
hectic it brought every
thing in my life because it gave me like
a bit of a chip on my shoulder
and it kind of made me
it put me in scenarios of like working
and
different thoughts and like what i that
i needed to succeed and i needed to do
something different i want to turn out
like him and there were times where i
was going to be like him and there were
all these different things that i had
learned
from that lesson
so as i grow older i look back on it and
it was
tumultuous i mean i remember at a young
age um
there are a lot of weird things that
happen now that i look back when i talk
about it with my mom sometimes i mean
there was a time where the fbi came and
raided my house and they were looking
for my dead grandmother because
everything was put in her name
um there was
all these strange occurrences of like
you know waiting sitting on the stoop
where he's supposed to come and get you
for the weekend and he never shows right
and it's like it's like out of a movie i
was just gonna say that that's like wow
it's like out of a movie where they come
to the show and then when they do show
they were trying to did show and he was
hammered and like you know you're in
this car and you're like i'm gonna
[ __ ] die on this thing and all of
that stuff starts to play into
who you become and you're gonna go one
way or the other and i've definitely
gone all the ways you know as
as the as the macho man randy savage
once famously said i've soared with the
eagles and i've slithered with the
snakes and everything in between right
yeah but you gotta keep moving forward
it's like all those things leave
impressions on your brain and you start
to grow up really fast so i started
doing things
at a super young age
that
i'm happy now because they made me who i
am
but as having two young kids i'm like
that was too young
that was too young to do those things i
think but again i don't know right it
just i know life is what it is so i was
around i was of all women right my
sister my mom my nana you know i was
around all women and it was amazing it's
an incredible way to be raised because i
was able to
have the toughness of where i grew up
and have the the
the
i should say the the
the smarts the fragility the smarts and
the and and the the intestinal fortitude
and tenacity of the women who are around
me
and
i think that that prepared me for life
and i think that i my mom was an artist
she's a dressmaker
my
birth father before he even though he
led a extremely criminal lifestyle was a
really wonderful artist um a great
designer was it was very smart but again
never almost like yusuf in emily the
criminal never
he wanted more but he was thrust into
this life right
um
[Music]
and that was just the beginnings but
then i went through you know i did all
the typical
you know hectic stuff of figuring out
who i was i just got really fortunate
that i figured it out
uh before i was too old
did you get pretty deep into things
because i know you came out with openly
to say that you were dealing drugs and
things like that were there times where
you could have died many times
i've been in some really precarious
situations let me fix this camera
i was in some precarious situations
meaning that
i didn't know any better i was i was not
equipped
for
i was not okay so if you're if you're
from a family of lawyers
you kind of on yeah we're gonna you're
gonna be a lawyer or you know military
families a lot of guys follow or women
follow in the footsteps of their father
and join you know and go downrange and
join
so you're kind of raised by the thing
around you so when there's no one there
when the goal is survival
you figure it out and for me
when it came to you know hustling and
dealing drugs and doing whatever i was
doing it was just because it was the
only thing i knew how to do i always say
that no criminal wants to do crime they
just do it because they don't really
[ __ ] know what else to do right no
one's giving them another
uh avenue and then you go well you can
go work here i remember that i remember
when i went to go try and work at
blockbuster my freshman year in college
and they were like okay so you have to
wear tan pants go get those i was like i
don't have any money to get 10 [ __ ]
pants and then they were like okay and
you're gonna get i think back then it
was like 275 an hour and i was like 275
an hour
i could flip an ounce and make 600. why
would i do that it sounds ridiculous
because again i just always thought of
life in time
so this scenario was never like oh yeah
but you're not going to go to jail for
[ __ ] putting away fast times in
richmond high the wrong way i wasn't
thinking
when i was doing it right it was it was
just
it was just
i can do this and that seemed more
reasonable
yeah and there was no one there going
it's not reasonable let me tell you why
it was just me and my own brain and the
people who were around me who had the
same mindset as me
who were going yeah [ __ ] it let's just
let's just flip some let's go grab 20
pounds and do this and you go oh cool
because it made more sense so again i
think it's what your
your what's in your toolkit what do you
have for you and i didn't have i had
different
set of skills as they would say i didn't
have the right set of skills maybe i
guess in
societal terms but
i learned them
you